la firma de un contrato petrolero que
entierra parte de las tensiones entre
Estados Unidos y Venezuela autorizado
por Washington este acuerdo comercial
con la empresa estadounidense Chevron le
permite reanudar sus actividades en el
país aún sometido a sanciones económicas
por parte de Estados Unidos condenada al
aislamiento desde la reelección de
Nicolás maduro en 2018 Caracas vive una
crisis económica y social por ello el
gobierno venezolano aplaudió esta
posible reanudación de las exportaciones
de crudo a Norteamérica a nombre del
gobierno bolivariano del presidente
Nicolás Maduro Moro a nombre de todo el
equipo de pedevesa y de la clase
trabajadora
celebramos
la firma de estos contratos y
le agradecemos a todos los que han
participado
obligado a prescindir de los
hidrocarburos rusos desde el inicio de
la guerra en Ucrania Estados Unidos se
plantea recurrir a Caracas una decisión
facilitada por la firma de un acuerdo la
semana pasada entre el gobierno
venezolano y la oposición en el exilio
un proceso que tiene como objetivo la
organización de elecciones libres en el
país vamos a dialogar
porque nosotros queremos una elecciones
libres en Venezuela
libres de sanciones libres de medidas
coercitivas unilaterales o hay
elecciones libres sanciones o hay
elecciones libres de sanciones Ahí está
El dilema elecciones libres quieren
justas y transparente elecciones libres
de sanciones
nos espera que este regreso de la
petrolera estadounidense chevrona
Venezuela revolucione el mercado mundial
del crudo el país representa actualmente
el 1% de la producción mundial de oro
negro